Alright, let's get started. First things first. Make sure you
get all your ingredients out and ready from the cupboards.
[MUSIC]
Now once you have everything out, you're going to want to take
your rubbing alcohol and put it in the freezer' because
we're going to need it to be chilled for later. Okay,
now it's time for you to get your strawberries out. Now,
if you're like me, you went to the grocery store
and actually bought some fresh strawberries. Ideally you want your strawberries
to be. Kind of fresh, but maybe a little mushy,
a little soft. If they're too hard they have a hard
time breaking down. You can also, get frozen
strawberries from your grocery's dessert section. When you thaw
them, they're really mushy already and you can use
those. What we're going to do is we're going to
take our fork. And we're actually going to cut the
head off the strawberry. We're going to use two strawberries.
I'm going to cut it into a couple of pieces
here. And now I'm going to get some hot water.
Make sure you run the tap for a little bit first.
You really want to make sure you got some really warm water.
[MUSIC]
Okay. You want to add about a quarter of cup of really hot water from the
tap, into one of your drinking glasses. And
you're going to drop in your chopped up strawberry.
[SOUND].
Come in close, and tell me from these items here, which of the two
item we're going to add so that we can actually help break up the strawberries.